all right okay
where'd you grow up where you from
originally um i'm from sacramento
and tell me about your your family do
you have both your parents when you were
young
you are still young but what how are you
raised
um i was raised mostly with my mother my
both my parents were really young um
both
19 and at 20 when they
had me and i'm 25
now when throughout the years my mom
has been pretty consistently my main
parent
i did get to go visit my father
who lived in a different part of
sacramento than i did
so it just was really two different
worlds
and a lot of the time it was not very
safe environment for children although
there was a lot of them running around
and
um what was going on
most of the time it was not very
supervised other than
the older cousins and my um
my grandmother and my grandfather on my
paternal side
so um just a lot of nonsense went on
and um you know some early
you know alcohol and drug use as well as
you know
um other stuff you know
and um the other stuff being like
i'm guessing sexual abuse or stuff like
that um there was yeah there's a little
bit of that going on
over there which is why i wasn't really
allowed over there
after about like 9 or 10 years old um
so then that kind of made the visits
with my father a little hard
and something happened with you at some
point yeah
yeah so that made things kind of hard to
see my
my father because he had um
lots of different relationships and
women
and um he kind of was
a player yeah so i i got to see a lot of
that
so you know that kind of
um made it so i was always really glad
to go home
to my mom my mom was my superhero and my
best friend
and shoes everything everything
when i was a kid she she was
all i wanted to be around i was really
shy
when i go to school i would be
kind of quiet kind of awkward at first
and then after a while once i got
comfortable
i wouldn't be able to focus i
wouldn't be behaving and
all that stuff you know i'd be too
worried about talking
in class i wouldn't be doing my
schoolwork so that's
towards the end of the year my grades
would be horrible
always without fail so eventually
i think it was third grade i got tested
for adhd
and i was tested positive and so they
said that i needed to take
medicine my mom didn't want to put me on
it first because
she didn't want me to become an addict
to these pills
so i just decided uh she just decided to
give me
like coffee and other alternatives until
um the decision was made to just put me
on
ritalin
that was considered less addictive
and so i took it for a while i didn't
like it
we tried all kinds of different
medicines and it seemed like the older i
got
the worse my behavior was getting and
the more
depressed and anxious i was feeling
i always had this feeling inside of just
like something
something isn't right about me like
there's something wrong with me and uh
i would lay up at night just thinking
about it my brain would just
race it still does but um
so eventually you know fast forward to
you know middle school which i'm pretty
sure is uncomfortable for everybody
um i was the late bloomer i didn't
get you know puberty with my friends
didn't have boobs i didn't have none of
that you know
the guys that i liked looked at me like
little sister and
they looked at my friends that were
developed already
as the girls they wanted so um
that kind of fed into eating disorder
and
body dysmorphia so already at a young
age i had all kind of mental issues
going on that i wasn't dealing with
no matter not that that wasn't my mom's
fault she
she tried i just wasn't listening so um
i got to high school and i still looked
like a kid
um yeah so i got to high school and then
that just was more uncomfortable for me
i was kind of anti-social
i didn't really do well um
i did good in in class at first but then
um i
just didn't want to be there anymore so
i just started ditching
and hanging out with the wrong crowd and
eventually
um sophomore year i uh lost my virginity
which for most
people isn't a huge deal but for me it
was because i was saving myself for
marriage
and the only reason that i did is
because um halloween
i got a beer from a stranger and
it had something in it and if i wouldn't
have taken that i wouldn't have
done that so unfortunately i did it with
a friend's
older brother so she was very angry
and um she spread rumors about me around
the school
that weren't true and threatened me
every day and
it was it got to the point where she was
throwing stuff and cussing me out at my
mom's car
after school in front of my mother so
um i started getting bullied really bad
which i'd dealt with bullying before but
nothing like this so
that made me go into a deep depression
and my anxiety was really bad i wasn't
going to any classes
and um one day
i decided to try some weed that was the
first
thing i tried or i tried um
some alcohol i tried some vodka that's
what it was
i got drunk for the first time and
um that's all it took i
i started off as binge drinking and
drinking whenever i could and then i
tried weed and then i was smoothing that
whenever i could and
and eventually come junior year
i was getting kicked out of school
because
i uh i showed up to school blacked out
drunk
it was our third period so that was
really bad and
um nobody in my family except
uh i think one other person graduated
from high school so that was a big goal
of mine
to do and so because i didn't do that
i just i really went like book wild
after that
and i had already been sneaking out a
lot and running away from home
but after that i just was more out on
the streets
than um than at home
and that was really scary for my mom
because
she and i had always been so close and
always told each other everything
so um now
i eventually turned 18
and at this time i had been in with my
mother had been there for not very long
about a month and she said
you know since your 18th birthday is
coming up i'm going to plan a big party
for you
you know um this is going to be great
but i need you to
um follow my rules still and you know no
drinking
no drugs at the party because you're
going to have family there
that's like um yeah okay and it wasn't
gonna be on my actual birthday though
because it was on a weekday so i was
like disappointed we weren't gonna do
anything because i was grounded
so i called my best friend on my
birthday and
convinced my mom to let me go over there
and stay the night at her house
um and so i was gonna go over there but
then she kind of said
something was off so then she was like
actually i want you home by midnight
i was like it's my birthday it didn't
matter home by midnight or your party's
off
and so i hadn't had a birthday in like
three years because i was being a
troublemaker so this was
a big deal so i went over there and
of course got wasted and
um didn't even end up staying home we
went
gallivanting all around sacramento
celebrating my birthday
and um that's when um
that's when my drinking got really bad
and um
my mom couldn't take it anymore she she
said no more you can't come back here
you can't come back here you and you're
not gonna ever live under my roof again
unless you're getting clean
and um at this point i'm smoking meth
too
and uh i've been through all kind of
other really bad stuff as a teenager
from being
kidnapped and um really pimped a few
times you know
all kinds of sexual abuse and through
all this it didn't matter to me because
i had my alcohol and i have my crystal
none of that mattered and
um i knew how to turn it all off
just pretend like everything was fine so
i drank for every day the moment i woke
up tomorrow i blacked out
from my 18th birthday to well past my
19th
i drank at least a handle at a time
i was drunk i i smaller than this i was
drinking grown men under the table
everybody would be passed out and i'd go
go around cleaning up their drinks
and finishing off the old beers
because i wasn't drunk enough yet and
uh now i can say you know
that kind of just continued the same old
[ __ ] but
now i can say uh it actually has been
five years as of june
20 25th or 26th
something like that um no alcohol at
least
um and it's been a few months no weed as
well
but anyways i think it was 21
21 i met a guy uh he told me he was
doing you know this at this point
i'm still in sacramento um and out of my
mom
still um i had already
gotten my first felony and i was on
five years of felony probation which i'm
almost done with
and i
i was on real estate ice over there
so i was out and i met this guy
and he told me that he smokes dope
and i had already been living with him
for a couple of weeks and i
told him you know go ahead i noticed you
get agitated and
you need to smoke it's like i used to
smoke um crystal
um but at this time i had smoked in two
years so i was like go ahead
smoke your dope you know i don't mind
you know blow it in my face if you want
to i guarantee you i won't want it
and so here okay so we get back um
from having dinner and he breaks out a
piece of foil
and um and a lighter and a straw and i
was like what the heck
it's like i've never seen anybody smoke
dope this way he's like yeah
you can smoke this way you could smoke
anything
on the foil really i was like okay cool
um so then he gets out this really dark
stuff and in my head i'm thinking okay
that must be some burnt crystal out of
the bubble or something
so then he you know melt it down and
hits it and
i i smell it and i'm like oh that smells
so good what is that and
he's like what do you mean this is dope
and he's like
uh this is heroin you've never had
heroin
i was like no this was really good
though let me have some
smells like fresh baked raisin bread and
it took a lot of convincing on my part
but eventually i manipulated him into
letting me have some
because i told him it's better me having
some there
being safe than um the latter
so basically that started my opiate
addiction
so what are you using now
um
a couple years ago it was um
homeless in oakland and um
i ended up getting a
boyfriend that was also my dealer and he
was selling me my black
and uh he was cutting my uh his uncle
was cutting my black
with fentanyl um both of them knowing i
was really against fentanyl because
i just watched it destroy people's lives
and kill people
um and so they decided to um
whenever i would complain that their
stuff wasn't getting me
well anymore they would just add more
fentanyl
and um eventually his uncle did teach my
boyfriend
how to do it himself and he would um
he would just keep adding more and one
day he realized
um that i wasn't getting well again
and that he was gonna have to add pretty
much mostly fat
no just a little bit of black and that
he might as well just buy some straight
fentanyl
and give it to me and tell me the truth
and so he did that
and that pretty much changed my life for
the worst
i've been addicted to it since um
i believe from the first hit
it it's it's really changed me as a
person
um i didn't contact my mother for two
years
i didn't contact anyone in my family and
that's not me at all
i did i was so ashamed and in a really
dark place i just couldn't let them see
me in my mess and
nonetheless hear hear my voice in my
mess
so um i'm still smoking it
i smoked right before this interview um
my taunt is really really high but um
the scary part is that i am allergic
to narcan which is what they give you
when you
overdose to bring you back to life
i'm allergic to it um and i did
uh not a lot of people know this but i
did uh overdose
i was in my tent in
oakland um with a guy that i
had been friends with for a little bit
and he said that
i took i'd gotten like a really good
deal on like
some of the best fentanyl i've ever had
i put it all
on foil and it was like an absurd amount
but i was like showing off you know
and so i i just remember taking one big
hit
and he said i pretty much took one big
hit and then like
fainted i just passed out he said he
he tried to get my me to wake up and i
wasn't waking up and then he was yelling
at me and
i wasn't responding um he said that
he kind of got me to like mumble and
then after that
my breathing was really shallow he said
he couldn't actually tell if i
was breathing and if he couldn't tell if
i had a heartbeat
but um he had had some stuff on his
record where he was too scared to call
the police he was too scared to call
9-1-1
and no one else around there would
anyway so he just ran
and left me there
um he i believe he did know
that i didn't smoke um
or that i didn't use narcan because i
was allergic
so he didn't even bother trying to find
anyone with some
he just left me there he said he tried
compressions
nothing was working so he just left me
and i woke up
two days later i didn't know two days
had passed
so today you're living today in the
streets
yeah shortly after that i i moved out of
oakland because of
you know all the bad memories and
especially that one
um
i i moved out here to san francisco also
because it was closer to
the fentanyl the good the good fentanyl
you know
um i started getting bunk [ __ ] and
having to walk around all around oakland
just to find it
or get on the bar and come here if
you're i might as well just move out
here
um how do you support yourself now
i do never have to do um
i i still i mean i have my own our power
my beliefs and i
i talk to my god and
and through all that i can say that he
sticks by my side and blesses me i
believe in karma
you know and i don't i don't steal from
people
you know i can't say i've never stolen
from somebody i've stolen from people
before but they had it coming
you know i hear that it was for my
safety yeah i needed to
to get out of there and go get safe
um but i have pretty good comment for
that reason
so people especially lately keep
stealing from me
and then i just i get blessed with stuff
like
these clothes um i had just kind of lost
everything i owned again
just the other day i had nothing and
um my friend today gave me a huge bag
full of really nice clothes
um and i was so excited i
you know i put them up this was one of
the things that was in the bag this
outfit
um and then i was blessed to
make a friend that um took me shopping
for
shoes you know it took me a salvation
army and
uh i'm not gonna lie we were both broke
and so he actually watched my back while
i stole these
shoes but um they're so cute and they
matched my toenails
so so is sex work one of the things
you'll
do to support yourself it used to be
more so now
i usually prefer more
like sugar daddy type of thing where
like
they're more of like a friend and um
he just helps me out with money with
whatever i need
i don't really like to do that sex work
anymore because
uh i used to be forced into that and so
that's
really just really triggering for me
what do you worry about now what are you
afraid of
dying or or killing my mother
um as far as her heart goes
i worry about every day
every day and i have to use because the
anxiety is so high now and i have been
using this
really strong drug to numb my pain for
so long i don't even know how to do it
i tried going to rehab and after finally
getting
the fog lifted um
and finally having my first normal day
with
no nothing in my system
i left and it ran and came back to san
francisco
from sacramento because i could not
handle my first emotion clean and sober
it had been that long i didn't know what
to do
i panicked and i ran the news
i regretted it as soon as i walked out
the door but it was too late
so now uh i don't know um
i just want to have a normal life um
i want to go back to you know
being outdoors and hiking and
you know going you know to indian
springs is pretty cool but don't check
it out
um camping instead
you know i mean nice guy who's normal
and does normal [ __ ] too
you know get a good job any job at this
point
would be awesome um i'll go to school
and and make my music because i
sing and write just do normal life [ __ ]
i have normal life problems like
my car is out of gas you know a block
from work i have to walk
it'd be a cool problem now do you have
friends
um i have friends
and straight acquaintances
but i can't really trust anybody out
here
there's people who i come real close to
trusting
um more than anybody else but
you know in the past i've ever had those
kinds of people
mistrust me in like the worst ways
possible so
i'll never let that last little guard
down
are you lonely yeah yeah it's pretty
lonely out here
it's pretty cold it's cold yeah
even though it's june it's still really
cold at night
yeah it is it is
i remember one night in oakland uh it
was this
old man's birthday and i was alone
too i was standing there i needed a
cereal i had a horrible night
and he'd had a pre [ __ ] night too for it
being his birthday
and so he you know give me a cigarette
and we
agreed to spend his birthday with him
and we were smoking and hanging out and
it was time to go to sleep
and we were both homeless and we were
just kind of
um behind and on the side of a couple of
buildings
and we both didn't really have any
blankets
um but i had a big suitcase with a bunch
of clothes and jackets and
um uh one dry towel
um and so i made this like a little
palette
and a little pillow out of clothes
and um it was so cold that night and
i think it was like just at the freezing
level
it wasn't a little winter we would have
probably gotten really sick if we didn't
you know
use body temperature but we both agreed
it'd be a little inappropriate
to do the whole naked and the snow thing
who we had to close on lots of layers
and we had to
hold a perfect stranger to to stay alive
that night
i'll never forget that
that's really that's really scary what
would you say is the most
important lesson you've learned from all
this
is that just because i have to listen to
my own
instincts and trust myself and not
listen to the other [ __ ] trying to
lead me straight doesn't mean that i
know everything
that's a really hard concept for me to
grasp
i'm not god
okay well thank you so much for sharing
your story
i hope you figure out all your emotions
so you can
maybe get free from from all your
addictions
you're still so young yeah
you